Ácido clorhídrico, el amienemigo de los químicos,
es tan terriblemente peligroso como terriblemente
útil. Quemará tu piel, tus ojos, incluso tus
membranas mucosas si respiras sus vapores por
mucho tiempo. Pero el HCl como es un ácido,
cede su hidrógeno con bastante facilidad,
por eso es bueno para hacer fertilizantes,
colorantes e incluso sal de mesa. También
está el hidróxido de sodio, aunque me alegro de
que exista, es otra sustancia que no desearía que
tuviera mi peor enemigo. Lo conocemos como lejía,
es sustancia extremadamente cáustica que se puede
usar para todo, desde limpiar tuberías obstruidas
hasta purificar el agua potable. Es una base,
acepta fácilmente los protones que liberan los
ácidos. Entonces ¿qué crees que pasará cuando
mezclemos estas dos soluciones?, ¿se cancelarán
entre ellas y no pasará nada?, ¿explotarán o
tal vez viajemos en el tiempo? Bueno, si
has puesto atención, ya sabrás qué pasará:
van a sufrir una reacción de neutralización de
la que hemos hablado con anterioridad. Estas dos
sustancias potencialmente mortales formarán agua
y sal inofensivas, pero la reacción también tendrá
un efecto que podremos sentir, liberará calor
y no sólo un poco de calor. Combinar ácidos y
bases concentrados libera tanto calor que
puede provocar una explosión. Te mostraré
cómo producir una cantidad de calor segura
pero perceptible con esta reacción. Para mí,
la parte más divertida es de dónde viene el calor:
proviene de la energía que es parte de los enlaces
químicos en el ácido y en la base. Como una
pelota en la cima de una colina, las moléculas
siempre se mueven hacia el estado de menor energía
posible y esto es justo lo que harán: los enlaces
de alta energía se romperán y los enlaces de baja
energía se formarán, y podemos sentir los efectos
del cambio de energía entre estos dos estados. Eso
es bastante genial. Lo que es más impresionante,
si me preguntas, es que podemos calcular
exactamente cuánto calor liberará la reacción.
Recuerda que medir el cambio de calor está
estrechamente relacionado con la entalpía,
que definimos como la energía interna de
un sistema más la energía que usa para
hacer retroceder el ambiente circundante
y dejar espacio para su presión y volumen
a una presión constante [H = E + PV], como
tenemos aquí en la superficie de la Tierra,
resulta ser exactamente igual al calor
que absorbe o libera una reacción.
Esto nos ayudará a saber qué tanto calor es
liberado o absorbido por una reacción química,
además de los calentadores para mano exotérmicos
que vemos en el mercado, también hay paquetes de
enfriamiento endotérmicos de productos químicos
para el tratamiento de lesiones. Los pilotos
también usan la capacidad de calcular el cambio y
la entalpía para saber qué tan lejos podrán volar
dependiendo del combustible que hay en el tanque
del avión. Y en lo personal, me interesa mucho
que se aseguren de que el avión pueda llegar.
Una de las formas de calcular el cambio en la
entalpía de un sistema es con la Ley de Hess
que, como recordarás, nos dice que el cambio
total de la entalpía para una reacción química no
depende del camino que tome, sólo depende de los
estados inicial y final. Todo esto está expresado
en términos de la entalpía estándar de formación:
la cantidad de calor perdida o ganada cuando se
forma un mol de un compuesto desde sus elementos
constituyentes. Así es como encontramos la
cantidad exacta de calor que liberan mis
calentadores de manos. Pero esta no es la única
forma en la que podemos utilizar la Ley de Hess,
la ley misma no nos dice nada sobre la entalpía de
formación; cualquier forma de encontrar el cambio
en el calor entre los productos y los restantes
funcionará bastante bien. Aquí es donde entra
la calorimetría. La calorimetría es la ciencia
que mide el cambio en el calor asociado con una
reacción química. Esto de aquí puede parecer una
botella de plástico dentro de una funda aislante,
pero en realidad es un calorímetro. Un calorímetro
puede ser una elegante y cara pieza de hardware o
puede ser algo muy simple, pero no importa cómo
se vea, básicamente es un contenedor aislado que
incluye un termómetro y puede estar hecho de acero
inoxidable o de una taza de espuma de poliestireno
y no hay diferencias importantes en cómo
funcionan. Ya sabemos la configuración general:
las sustancias químicas en el calorímetro
conforman el sistema termodinámico y todo
lo demás es el ambiente, el aislamiento minimiza
la cantidad de calor que se filtra hacia o desde
el sistema, por lo tanto, podemos estar bastante
seguros de que cualquier transferencia de calor
es parte del sistema y no del ambiente. El
termómetro registra el cambio de temperatura,
que es parte de los cálculos que debemos hacer.
Generalmente hay una forma de revolver para estar
seguros de que la reacción ocurra por completo.
Bien, la seguridad es primero, aunque realmente
debería estar usando guantes. Voy a poner 100
mililitros, que en este caso es equivalente a
100 gramos de ácido clorhídrico. Una solución
de HCl en mi calorímetro hasta la última gota,
y luego pondré la misma cantidad de solución de
hidróxido de sodio. Antes de hacer la reacción,
necesitamos conocer la temperatura inicial, así
que pondré el termómetro por aquí y esperaré
unos segundos para registrarla. Debería ser
aproximada a la temperatura ambiente, ya que
han estado en este cuarto durante mucho tiempo,
así que la temperatura actual es de 20.8°C,
esto es 294 K. Y ahora agregaré mis 10 mililitros
de hidróxido de sodio. La temperatura, como era
de esperar, está aumentando muy rápido, y en
estos momentos estoy haciendo algo que tú nunca,
nunca debes hacer: revolver con el termómetro. Si
esto ocurriera en las escuelas, en todo el mundo
tendríamos millones de termómetros rotos, y lo que
contienen no es nada bueno, así que nunca hagan
lo que estoy haciendo. Muy bien, la temperatura
parece estable en este momento, tenemos 28.2°C,
y existe una sencilla fórmula que nos permite
encontrar el cambio en el calor de la reacción
al medir el cambio en la temperatura que ocurrió
en el calorímetro. Tenemos que el cambio en el
calor es igual al calor específico de la sustancia
por la masa total por el cambio y la temperatura,
así que examinaremos las partes de esto.
Primero, el cambio en el calor en la fórmula
del calorímetro se representa normalmente por una
q minúscula, pero también puede representarse como
el cambio y la entalpía o delta H [∆H], ya que,
recordemos que la presión constante ∆H = q. Y la
presión constante siempre es una buena suposición
durante el curso de un experimento o al menos
mientras nos quedamos en la superficie de la
Tierra. Por razones que aclararemos después,
usamos ∆H para representar el cambio en
el calor en este experimento. El calor
específico representado por la letra s minúscula
es la cantidad de calor requerida para elevar la
temperatura de una unidad de masa, como
1 gramo o 1 kilogramo de una sustancia,
por 1 grado Celsius. Entonces resulta que
diferentes cantidades de calor crean diferentes
cambios en la temperatura. Por ejemplo, los
metales se calientan y se enfrían muy fácilmente;
otras sustancias como el agua requieren mucha
energía térmica para aumentar su temperatura y,
por lo tanto, tienen que liberar mucho calor para
enfriarse. Siempre me pregunto ¿qué significa eso
físicamente en las moléculas?, ¿será que el calor
no eleva la temperatura de todas las sustancias
de la misma manera? y ¿por qué es que el agua en
particular tiene un calor específico tan alto? La
energía calorífica puede hacer muchas cosas además
de aumentar la temperatura. La temperatura, o la
velocidad a la cual las moléculas rebotan, es sólo
una forma en que los átomos o las moléculas pueden
obtener energía. La energía calorífica también
puede absorberse para la formación o ruptura de
enlaces entre las moléculas, y, como aprenderemos
en otro episodio, el calor específico del agua es
tan alto debido a la ruptura y formación de los
enlaces de hidrógeno que están asociados con los
cambios relativamente pequeños en la temperatura.
¿Cómo conocemos el calor específico? Bueno,
me hace muy feliz informar que algunos químicos
nobles trabajaron duro para determinar el calor
específico de cientos de sustancias para
que no tengamos que hacerlo nosotros,
sólo tenemos que buscar los valores en una tabla.
Muy bien, entonces el calor específico multiplica
a la masa total, que a su vez multiplica al
cambio en temperatura-. La masa es importante, ya
que a mayor masa de la sustancia que tengamos se
presentan más enlaces químicos, y como la energía
está contenida en los enlaces químicos, entonces
éstos tienen un gran efecto en la cantidad de
energía que se puede absorber o liberar. Por
último, tenemos el cambio en la temperatura.
Cuando se realiza una calorimetría calculamos
el cambio en el calor al medir el cambio en la
temperatura, pero como hemos dicho millones
de veces, el calor y la temperatura no son
lo mismo. Por favor, no pienses que esta cosa mide
el calor porque no es así, afortunadamente en este
caso específico están relacionados con nuestra
práctica fórmula del calorímetro. Ahora puede que
no te hayas dado cuenta, pero aquí estamos en la
interfaz de la Química y la Física. Cada ciencia
puede reclamar propiedad sobre este fenómeno, pero
la verdad es que son los humanos los que separan
la Física y la Química. A la termodinámica, que
estudia el calor, la energía y el trabajo no le
interesan nuestras reglas insignificantes. La
termodinámica, por sí sola, hace las reglas del
universo, esa es la ley fundamental. Así que ahora
ya lo sabes, aunque no te importe, pero debería,
porque es genial, súper, ultra, mega maravilloso.
Muy bien, suficiente plática. Vamos, es momento de
hacer las matemáticas correspondientes. Recuerda
que la fórmula es ∆H = sm ∆T. Las soluciones que
estamos usando aquí están tan diluidas que casi
toda su masa consiste en agua, por lo tanto,
podemos usar simplemente el calor específico del
agua. Si lo buscamos en una tabla, podemos ver que
es 4.184 J/gK. Por otra parte, usamos 100 gramos
de cada reactante para una masa total de 200
gramos, y finalmente necesitamos el cambio en la
temperatura. Si recuerdas, la temperatura aumentó
de 294 Kelvin a 301.4 Kelvin, la diferencia
entre estas dos temperaturas es de 7.4 Kelvin,
y es un valor positivo porque se incrementó
de la temperatura. Cancelamos las unidades
correspondientes y luego de unos golpes en la
calculadora obtenemos 6,192.32 Jules liberados
o cerca de 6.2 KJ en esta reacción. Debido a que
la fórmula se basa en el cambio de temperatura
y dado que la temperatura aumentó, terminamos
con un valor positivo; pero lo más importante
es que nos da la magnitud del cambio en la energía
calorífica. Así que me pregunto: ¿cómo se compara
esto con la cantidad que predijimos al usar la
Ley de Hess y la entalpía estándar de formación?
Recuerda que podemos ver la entalpía estándar de
formación para todos los productos y reactantes
en la parte de atrás de un libro de texto o
en línea. La reacción química entre el ácido
clorhídrico y el hidróxido de sodio produce agua
líquida y cloruro de sodio, la entalpía estándar
de formación del ácido clorhídrico es de -167.2
KJ/mol, para la hidróxido de sodio es de -469.15
K/mol, para el agua líquida es de -285.8 k/mol y
para el cloruro de sodio es de -407.27 K/mol. No
vamos a hacer todos los cálculos de los moles en
la pantalla, pero créeme cuando te digo que usamos
0.100 moles de HCl y la misma cantidad de NaOH.
Ya que todo en la ecuación se balancea, tenemos
una razón de 1 a 1 a 1 a 1. Podemos suponer que
tenemos la misma cantidad de cada producto. Si
sustituimos esto en la Ley de Hess y hacemos
los cálculos, encontraremos que el cambio en
el calor o entalpía de la reacción es de -5.67 KJ,
y el sistema está liberando o perdiendo energía,
entonces tenemos un valor negativo. Pero de nuevo,
lo que queremos saber es la magnitud. Así que ahí
lo tienes, la fórmula de la calorimetría nos
da un valor absoluto en la entalpía de 6.2 KJ,
mientras que la ley de Hess nos da un cambio de
5.67 KJ. Entonces, ¿por qué la diferencia? Bueno,
la causa principal probablemente es que usamos el
calor específico del agua pura en lugar de usar el
del agua salada, que fue lo que obtuvimos; tampoco
incluimos el calor específico del calorímetro,
es decir, sus paredes y el termómetro también se
calentaron y esa parte del calor producido no se
contabilizó; el aislamiento del calorímetro,
obviamente es un poco ligero, lo que permite
que se escape un poco de calor y esa es otra
causa principal. Aún así diría que lo hicimos
bastante bien. Lo importante es que nos mostró
lo que necesitábamos ver a pesar de ser sólo una
pequeña botella de plástico dentro de una funda
aislante. Para ser un método simple y rápido,
el calorímetro nos acercó bastante al valor
calculado. Si estuviéramos calculando la
cantidad de un combustible en particular
necesario para viajar a marte o inventando
una compresa fría para que no te congele,
necesitaríamos usar un sistema un poco más
sofisticado y tendríamos más cuidado, pero este
funciona bastante bien para nuestros propósitos